bonsoir bonsoir je regarde l'heure il
est 21h30 passées
contractuellement c'est l'heure de
parler de l'inconnu ou plutôt de ma
fascination pour l'inconnu de nos
lendemains nos inconnu voyez quand deux
en une phrase j'ai cité deux fois le mot
inconnu avec des orthographes
différentes
la langue française est magnifique mais
ce n'est pas je ne suis pas futurologue
et je vais je vais c'est surtout de
parler comment en tant qu'artiste jeu
j'essaie d'imaginer le monde de demain
l'une des premières choses que j'aime à
dire j'aimerais évoquer un endroit
d'abord est un personnage l'endroit
c'est ma ville de naissance belgrade
vous savez que c'est une ancienne
capitale de la yougoslavie que c'est
maintenant la capitale de la serbie les
choses ont bougé très violemment et le
personnage c'est le maréchal tito
maréchal tito est responsable de ce que
je suis devenu et je vais vous expliquer
comment et pourquoi il est responsable
parce que il a vaincu les nazis dans les
balkans seconde guerre mondiale il les a
vaincus par son courage grâce à ses
partisans ces soldats parmi lesquels se
trouvait mon père il est responsable
aussi parce que il a pris en affection
mon père il lui a proposé d'être son
tailleur à la fin de la guerre ce que
mon père fut pendant un temps il est
responsable aussi parce qu'il a mis sous
mes yeux une ville que j'aime mes
enfants mais ils vivent qu'ils étaient
lézardées lacéré par la violence de la
guerre et qui n'a pas fait de ravalement
il n'a rien ravaler il a tout laissé
comme c'était en 45 à la fin des
hostilités
donc j'ai vécu j'ai joué dans ces
endroits là que j'aimais la ville se
trouve est sublime
c'est un terrain de jeu c'est un
formidable mais il est responsable aussi
d'avoir installé en face d'eux
chez moi dans un parc un musée à ciel
ouvert un musée de la guerre où on
pouvait voir les armes de la seconde
guerre mondiale même de l'ap de la
première des chars d'assaut des avions
des canons et cetera et tout ça moi je
jouais à la guerre dessus avec mes
petits camarades
donc tout ça c'est de la mémoire qui
s'accumulent de la mémoire de la
violence dans une ambiance de du
politique tendu dans une ambiance
géopolitique tendu dans une ambiance de
culte de la personnalité il responsable
aussi de m'avoir fait défiler parmi les
pionniers enfants avec un petit foulard
rouge dans les stades à sa gloire
et lorsque mon père est parti pour paris
et qu'on l'a rejoint beaucoup plus tard
il est responsable d'avoir laissé mon
père parti a finalement lui qui étaient
proches de lui à un moment c'est un
grand mystère
alors donc maintenant ciao ciao maréchal
tito jeu age arrive en france je suis
confronté à la vis de l'occident
je découvre une langue absolument
sublime la langue française celle qui
permet de citer deux fois le mot inconnu
et cette française me plaît énormément
parce que ne permet de raconter des
histoires et en même temps je me rends
compte que tito était aussi responsable
de m'avoir laissé dessinée sur les
trottoirs de belgrade est ma passion est
née sur les trottoirs de belgrade al
harra la craie donc je découvre en
france un genre littéraire
je connaissais pas ou pratiquement pas
se la bande dessinée franco belge
et c'est ainsi que l'écriture le dessin
m'amène à m'exprimer évidemment beaucoup
plus tard avec ceux avec ce que j'avais
lu mére de la part de ceux tito de ce
maréchal que finalement les yougoslaves
et mais bien parce que il les avait
sauvés et que finalement ils allaient
sauver aussi de staline ce qui ce qui
reste de cette enfance et sans doute
cette matière mystérieuse insidieuse qui
s'est placée en moi et qui fait que
graphiquement et va chercher sa source
dans ses souvenirs là dans cette mémoire
là ma rencontre avec pierre christin
nous amène à faire des livres politiques
un peu prospectifs les phalanges de
l'ordre noir est partie de chasse et
ensuite trace je travaille seul sur la
prospective toujours également avec
l'idée que les trois éléments du temps
forme une conjugaison c'est pas de la
grammaire c'est pas de la langue mais
c'est c'est de l'imaginaire vous
conjuguez le présent dans lequel on vit
avec la mémoire du futur du passé par
don que vous avez connues et vous
obtenez par la conjugaison une vision
qui est celle d'un avenir proche
c'est comme ça que j'ai fonctionné y
compris sur la matière terrible que fut
l'éclatement de la yougoslavie on y
revient à la yougoslavie c'était dans
les années 90 éclatement
pour des raisons que des médias que les
intellectuels n'ont pas vu ou pas voulu
voir pour des raisons aussi religieuse
cela m'amène à me poser la question de
l'inconnu du futur proche mondiale et
l'inconnu du futur proche mondiale en 95
lorsque je vois apparaître les talibans
en afghanistan
me fait imaginer quelque chose de très
plausible et qui va malheureusement
arrivé en 2001 le fameux 11 septembre
que tout le monde connaît qu qui a
sidéré le monde entier qui m'a sidéré
aussi mais qui ne m'a pas surpris alors
c'est ainsi que cette façon d'essayer de
regarder devant toujours est une façon
de de s'exciter l'imaginaire parce qu'il
ya ça aussi c'est pas le réel ne
m'ennuie pas au point de ne pas vouloir
le traité mais le décalé décaler le réel
d'une quelques quelques années
simplement fini par se pose poser des
questions juste que les journalistes ne
peuvent pas se poser et ça c'est le sait
le travail de l'artiste qui est
dit-on et moi je souscris à ca ca qui
voit les choses que les autres ne voient
pas ou qui voit au delà de ce que les
autres voient alors donc tout ce travail
accumulé avec un graphisme assez dur me
dit on on me dit qu'il est dur mon
graphisme alors sombre aussi
moi je pense que c'est un manque
d'humour je pense que c'est un manque
d'humour parce que attendez je sais pas
de la ch lire vos vies de saints je vous
assure c'est de l'eau je les envie de ça
c'est un accueil de prune serbe
non ce que ce qui en fait ce qu'il faut
faire c'est c'est me lire aussi pas
seulement regarder les images
si vous me lisez vous comprendrez qu'il
ya souvent et toujours un décalage la
redondance en littérature en écriture en
dessin et en peinture
c'est une catastrophe donc il ya
toujours quelque chose qui est qui et en
ce décalage dans cette dérision et qui
ce qui fait finalement que ce que je
raconte est peut-être peut être terrible
peut être visionnaire mais recèle
toujours une une zone ou l'intellect
peut se poser des questions on peut
discuter avec soi même avoir un peu de
un peu de distance
donc ça c'est le c'était pour me pour me
faire comprendre en tant qu'artiste à
ceux qui n'ont pas d'humour et qui ne
voient pas que ce que je dessinais
souvent très drôle mais c'est notre
monde est alors une autre monde alors
encore plus celui là dans lequel on est
tout ce qu'on a entendu cette soirée de
soirée et à ses essais et ses
exceptionnelles mais nous a montré que
ce monde était en marche et qui ne
donnait pas du tout possibilité de
retour il ya une rupture numérique
terrible effrayante et magnifique à la
fois l'outil de technologies modernes à
nouvelle est tout à fait fascinant et je
m'en sers le premier avec plaisir mais
ce
cette rupture est très brutal parce
qu'il ya une rupture de la mémoire
quelque chose qui est rarement arrivé
dans dans l'histoire de l'humanité parce
que si on prend par exemple
l'imprimerie une invention formidable
moi qui aime les livres je suis très
reconnaissant a dû timbert de son
invention
mais c'est une invention qui a mis du
temps à s'installer c'est une invention
qu'il a fallu porter dans les villages
de la dispersion des livres réimprimer
la multiplication des exemplaires tout
ça c'était merveilleux pour une élite 2
d'intellectuels d'écrivains de
philosophes mais la portée a mis du
temps à s'installer y compris toutes les
grandes révolutions et industriels du
19e siècle alors que l' état de
sidération immédiat le monde entier est
concerné un tsunami nous impose une
nouvelle façon de penser de vivre de
fonctionner ça crée évidemment une
rupture il ya des laissés pour compte il
ya des victimes personnes âgées
évidemment les premières mais c'est
cette une
quand je dis de rupture de mémoire il ya
aussi un déficit de transmission qui est
qui a imposé simplement par la violence
de l'événement donc on est face à sedan
ce monde-là façonne un inconnu qui n'est
plus si inconnu que ça parce que
finalement les pistes on les connaît et
son dessiner une nouvelle génération va
prendre les choses en main et il le fera
bien j'en suis sûr j'en suis sûr et elle
sait ce qu'elle doit vérifier
regardez checker et qui est devant et
qui n'est plus une inconnue c'est beau
les nanotechnologies c'est le
transhumanisme l'homme augmenté ses
l'immortalité
on peut y en a qui en rêvent c'est
l'intelligence artificielle
et si l'artifice devient plus
intelligent c'est plus embêtant on est
on est dans dans cette aventure qui se
dessine devant nous qui est une aventure
que je trouve parfaitement excitante et
en tant que auteurs artistes elle me
donne énormément de possibilités et nous
donne énormément de possibilités et la
culture se doit d'être présente sur ce
terrain aussi
mais là aussi les nouvelles générations
feront le boulot j'en suis sûr et
certain
donc on est on a on a les pistes c'est
une ligne de crête sur lequel il faut
avancer et je pense alors à un ami cher
qui est qui nous a quittés il ya peu de
temps quelques semaines paul virilio
alors paul virilio c'était un fréquentes
urbanistes un essayiste regard d'acier
acéré c'était quelqu'un de deux traits
du dic aussi de très joueur et il dit
c'est une chose très simple il disait
lorsque l'homme invente une nouvelle
invention chaque nouvelle invention de
l'homme invente aussi l'accident qui va
avec
ça paraît évident et c'est une évidence
mais qu'il faut pas perdre de vue parce
que avancé sur cette crête sur sa ligne
sur cette lame de rasoir
c'est bien mais il faut le faire avec
alix avec solidité avec lucidité
il faut que la colonne vertébrale
puisque la colonne vertébrale de
l'humain c'est la mémoire
il faut que cette colonne cela ce solide
soit en béton parce que la mémoire sans
mémoire
il n'y a pas de futur merci
[Applaudissements]